this line tracks the rise and fall
of inflation the rate at which prices
increase
across the economy
[Music]
for years central banks like america's
federal reserve
thought they understood why inflation
fluctuated and
how to keep it steady central banks felt
that as long as they could keep
inflation on an even keel it's probably
a sign that they were also keeping the
economy
on an even keel but for the past decade
inflation hasn't played by the rules
despite high employment before the
pandemic in places like america
which normally causes inflation to rise
it's been mysteriously low
across much of the rich world and
central banks
seem unable to revive it low inflation
means that central banks are less
powerful
than we thought or less powerful than we
hoped
this is particularly worrying as the
world faces a period of profound
economic uncertainty making it more
important than ever
to solve the great inflation mystery and
repair the global economy
[Music]
inflation is when prices rise across the
economy
it helps explain why a big mac cost less
than three dollars 20 years ago
but is nearest six dollars today the
traditional
explanation is too much money chasing
too
few goods according to this logic
if a central bank prints too much money
or makes it very easy to borrow money by
keeping interest rates low
then prices will rise
[Music]
events like wars which cause a shortage
of goods
can also increase prices so a little bit
of inflation
doesn't really hurt anybody but when
inflation is high and volatile
and when it's unexpected it can do a lot
of damage to the way
a capitalist system runs it can make
planning very difficult it can make
borrowing money and lending money very
difficult because you don't know how
much you're going to get back
and so in countries that suffer high
inflation you see a breakdown
in long-term borrowing
to avoid extremes of inflation most
central banks try to keep it at around
two percent
to stop inflation rising they can
increase interest rates
making it more expensive for everyone to
borrow money
which slows the economy and lowers
inflation
predicting when central banks need to
intervene to curb inflation
used to be pretty straightforward thanks
in part to observations published in
1958
by an economist from new zealand called
a.w phillips
he is a trending resourceful man as a
school child for example he rebuilt a
truck
from scratch and drove it himself to
school taking his friends along with him
he was also a prisoner of war during the
second world war and
famously created some secret radios and
tea heaters
[Music]
phillips observed that wages in britain
tended to rise faster if employment was
high
he plotted the relationship between
salary rates of change
and unemployment levels on a graph to
produce what is known
as the phillips curve the phillips curve
was used by central banks to help
predict
inflation as if lots of people were in
work and wages were rising
it tended to lead to price increases
if unemployment's low and wages are
therefore rising faster
that puts upward pressure on costs and
firms will
feel confident passing those higher
costs on into higher prices
because the economy is presumably doing
quite well
the opposite is also true when the
economy is weak and unemployment is high
wages stop rising and firms can't raise
prices much
without losing customers
this theory was pushed to the extreme in
the 1970s
a spike in the price of oil and
overspending to fund the vietnam
war meant that inflation was rising
rapidly in america
so paul volcker the head of the federal
reserve
raised interest rates to a record 20
percent
this huge hike in interest was known as
the volca shock
and brought inflation down by the 1980s
labor leaders are increasingly speaking
out about the credit crunch policies of
mr volcker's federal reserve
[Music]
it created mass unemployment in the u.s
but it did ultimately have the effect of
curbing inflation and as a result
inflation did come down
from double digits but the idea that ups
and downs in employment explain
changes in inflation didn't last giving
rise to one of the great economic
conundrums of the modern world
the signs were everywhere but now it's
official we are
in a recession we received yet another
round of alarming employment figures
the worst in more than 30 years the
global
financial crisis of 2007 to 2009
caused mass unemployment in america but
strangely
inflation didn't fall very far and as
the economy recovered and unemployment
reached a 50-year low in america in 2019
inflation remained mysteriously low
baffling economists and politicians
alike
some economists declared that the
phillips curve was dead i think a more
mainstream view was that it was merely
hibernating
this mystery of low inflation led to a
radical rethink about what was causing
prices to stagnate
one explanation is that central banks
have kept inflation
low for so long that people no longer
expect inflation to rise
even in a jobs boom and firms are more
reluctant to raise their prices or wages
if they don't expect anyone else to do
the same
another theory is that globalization has
helped keep prices low
because it's led to an influx of cheap
imports
central banks have run out of room uh to
cope with globalization
because interest rates have been so low
since the global financial crisis and so
if you do get
downward pressure on prices from for
example manufactured imports
from emerging economies central banks
don't anymore have the room to offset
that
by allowing other prices to rise faster
other economists say that because firms
didn't cut wages much during the
financial crisis
to protect worker morale they didn't
raise wages much during the recovery
and this slowed inflation pay
and inflation would eventually rise but
it would take time
and before inflation had the chance to
correct itself
the pandemic hit but an unexpected
outcome of the disruption caused by the
pandemic
might actually help raise inflation and
get it back on track
the u.s senate has unanimously approved
what is essentially two trillion dollars
of economic triage
lowering interest rates almost down to
zero the pandemic has led to far
greater cooperation between central
banks and governments
as central banks have printed money
governments have offered stimulus
packages
ensuring that people are able to spend
it if governments
can borrow and spend in knowledge that
they won't put
upward pressure on interest rates
because central banks will stop that
from happening
then that should be quite a powerful
stimulant to the economy
this cooperation could not only be
enough to pick inflation up off the
floor
it could also help repair the global
economy
i'm simon cox emerging markets editor of
the economist we've written a series of
articles looking at the basics of
economics
and how thinking about that is evolving
you can read more at the link opposite
thanks for watching